In the late 1920,
a young man outside of Tampa in Florida
picked up an ax and hacked his family to
death.
His name is Victor Lacarta.
At that point,
cannabis was not illegal in the United
States and a man called Harry anslinger.
I'd taken over the Department of Alcohol
Prohibition,
Justice,
Alcohol prohibition was ending,
so you inherited this huge government
department that's just lost the war and
alcohol.
It's riddled with corruption and he
wants to keep it going.
He had previously said that cannabis was
not dangerous,
shouldn't worry about it.
He's suddenly decided that cannabis was
the most evil.
Literally,
this is his words,
the most evil drug in the world.
He said,
I'm much worse than heroin.
he said,
if if Frankenstein's monster mutt
cannabis on the staircase that would
drop dead or fried,
and he latched onto the case of Victor
Lacarta with the help of the kind of Fox
News of his day,
which was called the hearst newspapers.
He announced that Victor Lacarta had
smoked cannabis.
That's why he'd hacked his family to
death with an ax,
and this is what will happen if we allow
cannabis to spread and we need to ban
and prohibit cannabis.
It was in the wake of that case that
cannabis is band.
Years later,
somebody goes back,
a researcher where many years later,
decades later,
a researcher went back and looked at
Victor Lacarta his files.
There's no evidence even smoke cannabis.
His family had been told he needs to be
institutionalized the year before
because it was severely mentally ill,
but they decided to keep him at home.
The origins of the war on drugs,
which I wrote about in my book,
chasing the scream.
The first and last days of the war on
drugs overwhelmingly looked like that.
If you'd asked me when I started doing
the research for chasing screen,
why was cannabis band?
I would have guessed they would have
given the reasons then,
but if you stop someone on the street
now,
they would give.
You know,
we don't want kids to use drugs.
We don't want people to become addicted.
What's fascinating is that stuff just
never,
virtually never came up when they were
banning cannabis,
right?
Or indeed the other drugs.
It was overwhelmingly a kind of racial
panic and absurd hysteria is about,
about what was going to happen.
Now,
the one thing you can say in defense of
the war on drugs in the world,
cannabis in particular,
is we've given it a fair shot,
right?
The United States has spent a trillion
dollars a,
it's imprisoned,
um,
more people than any other country in
human history,
including Stalin's Russia and China and
it's destroyed whole countries like
Columbia at the end of all that,
we can't even keep drugs out of our
prisons where we pay someone to walk
around the perimeter the whole time,
which gives you some idea of how well
we're ever going to keep that out of the
country with two,
3000 mile borders.
There is an alternative for how we can
think about cannabis.
There are places that have legalized
cannabis and we can see the results.
So I spent a lot of time in Colorado and
Washington state actually spent time in
places that have legalized other drugs.
Heroin,
for example.
It's been legalized in Switzerland with
extraordinary results.
There have been zero overdose deaths on
legal heroin in Switzerland in the more
than 13 years since they,
since they legalized.
But with cannabis specifically,
again,
we can see the results.
When you banned cannabis,
several things happen.
The first thing that happens is it you
will have noticed it does not disappear.
It's transferred from licensed legal
businesses to armed criminal gangsters.
Those armed criminal gangsters have to
operate differently to a licensed
business.
So you know,
you will have noticed the head of
Budweiser does not go and shoot the head
of Heineken in the face,
right?
Your local liquor store does not send
people to go and stab people in the
local bar.
Right,
exactly.
That happened at the alcohol
prohibition,
right?
I mean exactly that and it ended the day
alcohol prohibition ended.
Why?
Because when you band drugs,
they have to operate in an illegal
market where there's no,
and I learned this from lots of drug
dealers.
I spent time with the chasing the
scream,
not just for fun,
and there was some funding as well.
Um,
the,
the illegal market can only operate
through violence,
right?
You have no recourse to the Lord.
You're,
if,
if I go out of here now and I tried to
steal a bottle of vodka,
you know,
the liquor store,
we'll call the cops.
The cops will come and take me away.
So there's no need for that liquor store
to be violent,
to be intimidating if I go out of here
now and try to steal a bag of weed from
the people who sell it,
not so far away,
they can't call the cops.
The cops would come and arrest them.
They have to fight me now.
You don't want to be having a fight
everyday if you're a dealer.
So you got to establish a reputation for
being so frightening that people
wouldn't be so stupid as to come and
fight yet.
Right?
So this is the ratchet effect you get
with prohibition.
You create a market that can only be
regulated by violence and where there is
actually a premium on being the most
violent person and the most intimidating
person when you have to be violent,
intimidating to protect your market.
Now when you legalize that goes away
immediately.
That ended.
Whereas Al Capone,
it does anyone even know the head of
Smirnoff's name,
right?
Everyone watching this knows Al Capone's
name.
I bet nobody watching this knows the
head of smirnoff's name.
What changed?
It's not the drug,
it's the fact that it went from being
illegal and therefore controlled by
gangsters to legal and being controlled
by legal and licensed businesses.
The second thing that happens,
which is a slightly more wonky point but
I think is really interesting and
important,
is that milder forms of the drug
disappeared.
So you often get.
People say,
well,
we can't legalize cannabis because the
cannabis people use today isn't the
cannabis people used it in the 19
sixties,
right?
It's much stronger.
It's things like skunk [inaudible]
skunk.
That's true,
and it's entirely the product about
cannabis prohibition.
You want to understand why I got into
dancing just before alcohol was banned
in the United States,
most popular drinks by far were beer and
wine.
After alcohol is legalized.
Again,
most popular drinks by far were beer and
wine.
Is there a main today and when alcohol
was banned,
you couldn't get hold of barrel wine
anywhere.
Most popular drinks where whiskey and
Moonshine,
you think,
well,
why is that?
Why we're banning a drug change?
The form of the drug is kind of rather
prosaic reason,
and actually we had to smuggle enough.
You know,
alcohol for your local bar from the
Mexican border or the Canadian border,
right?
If we fill our wagon with a beer,
we'll get drink for 100 people.
If we fill our wagon with whiskey,
will get drink for thousands of people.
When you ban drugs,
there's suddenly a premium on getting
the biggest possible kick into the
smallest possible space because it's got
to be smuggled,
right?
It's got to be transported in secret.
This happens with all drugs.
This is what I kind of.
It's become.
It's become much more potent,
most popular form of consuming cocaine
prior to it being banned was intake coca
tea,
and you may remember a drink called Coca
Cola that really to contain exactly what
it sounds like,
they don't exist anymore.
Went to ever hear about Coker Tea,
right?
Coca Cola exists,
but it's not what it was.
Obviously,
the most popular way of consuming opiods
by far was a drink called laudanum and
something called Mrs winslow soothing
syrup.
That was a small trace of opiates,
right?
Again,
they disappear.
Most popular form becomes heroin when
you ban a drug,
only the most extreme forms of that
drugs have become available now.
Now,
most people who smoke cannabis don't
want skunk,
right?
Just like if I go into bar around the
corner from here today,
probably very few people are can be
drinking vodka and no one's going to be
drinking absinthe,
right?
If you're concerned about the more
extreme forms of the drug,
which I think we should be with cannabis
because there is,
it's not a huge relationship,
but there's some relationship with
dysfunctional behavior.
Then you want to pay a really high
premium on getting milder forms of the
drug available,
so almost all the users he wanted.
Right.
So that's another effect that happens
with legalization and you know,
one of the things that,
so moving everywhere I went,
but they've moved beyond the war on
drugs from Portugal where they
decriminalized all drugs to Switzerland
where they legalized heroin addicts to
Erg.
Why and Washington and Colorado where
they legalized cannabis.
The pattern was always the same.
It is super controversial at first and
understandably,
people are really worried and then they
see the effects.
It's not a silver bullet.
There's still problems,
but there's such a significant
improvement that the support massively
rises.
So 55 percent of people in Colorado
voted to legalize in 2015 today.
Seventy percent of people support it.
Governor Hickenlooper who opposed it now
says it works really well.
They've had a huge increase in tax
revenue.
I interviewed one former police officer.
He told me a story about this that
really stayed with me one day in the
seventies.
He was staking out a dealer in a car
park in Wayne,
New Jersey in plain clothes,
and a kid came up to him and said,
hey,
Mr,
where you go into that liquor store and
buy me some bs.
I'm not allowed to until young.
It was like a 12 year old or something,
and he said,
no,
get out of here.
What are you talking about?
Get out of here.
So the kid walked over to the drug
dealer and bought some drugs from him
instead.
And he had this kind of epiphany.
He's like,
oh,
actually,
legalization,
illegal regulated system puts a barrier
between children and drugs that does not
currently exist.
If you're a parent who doesn't want your
child to smoke cannabis,
and if you're a parent,
you shouldn't because there is evidence
that it can impair development.
Um,
for teenagers,
you want to put a really high premium on
getting cannabis out of the hands of
armed criminal gangs.
You don't care whether the customers are
13,
30 or 80 and getting into the hands of
licensed legal,
regulated businesses who have something
to lose.
This is why in Colorado all the research
shows that's been a really significant
fall in cartel and organized crime
activities.
They legalized.
There's been a fallen teenagers using.
It was already quite low,
but it's fallen.
There's been a massive increase in tax
revenue.
You know,
it's not perfect.
There were some things I would have
tweaked in the Colorado legalization,
but you know,
you can tweak a legal market,
wouldn't have any power over an illegal
market.
There's nothing we can do about it.
Right?
At some point,
the president of Switzerland,
Ruth Dreifuss,
when she made the case to the threats,
people for legalizing heroin,
it.
She's one of the great heroes I've ever
met in my life.
She explained to them,
you know,
when you hear the word legalization is
picture like anarchy and chaos.
What we have now is anarchy and chaos.
You have unknown criminals selling
unknown chemicals to unknown drug users.
All in the dark,
all filled with violence,
right?
Legalization is the way we restore order
to this chaos.
At some point we have to look at the
results.
It's worked incredibly well,
and let's look at the places that are
maintaining a criminal warrant cannabis.
How's that working out for you?